- You want to look fresh in the apocalypse? [Laughing]
Or do you want some money to barter?
- You always want to look fresh, Jeff. [Laughing]
- What's up, Kicks family.
It's Meech here.
Welcome to our new debate show,
"Sneaker Swap," where we argue a lot.
Fellas, the topic for today is if you
had the Dior Jordan 1, would you trade it
for a half a year's rent?
OK.
Five million people tried to
secure these sneakers.
Only 8,000 pairs were made
available to the public worldwide.
That is very, very, very rare.
What are we doing here? Christian,
I want to hear from you first, man.
- That's tough.
That's tough, man.
I can't even front, like, half a
year’s rent sounds mad good.
But I'm going Diors.
I'm keeping the Diors.
Like you said,
five million people have
tried to cop. Eight thousand pairs.
You gotta sit on that, bro.
You gotta sit on that.
Like, honestly, the Diors are gonna be the
most coveted pair since the Red Octobers
in, like, in 2014. Only other shoe that
might be even close is probably the Off-Whites.
And, like, I still think the Red
Octobers are higher than that.
And if you just think about it, like, the
people who kept the Red Octobers, like,
it was only 250 when it first dropped.
And people sold it for 4K.
Now it's looking like at 10K.
So you mean to tell me,
if I got these Dior 1s,
Right?
- Right.
- And they're going for like 15
right now, six years or so,
I’m looking at, what,
30K or so? I'm keeping that. Plus,
the shoe just feels luxury.
It feels like everything you want.
I don't want to see any other Jordan
logos out with Air Dior on top of it now.
So I'm keeping the shoe.
- I absolutely love to hear that, man.
Like, having these shoes is like being
a part of a very, very exclusive club.
- For a fact.
- Uh, C.J., talk to me.
- So I love you, Christian, man, and I
don't, and I, you got into the math,
which is a perfect way to break this
down, and I don't want to remind us
of this, but we are in a pandemic.
If I have the Diors, I got to sell
them if I can guarantee some rent.
I mean, so I'm in L.A. right now.
My rent six months, that's
like 2,000 a month.
That's like, you know, that's $12,000.
And also too, I'm a bad sneaker dealer.
Like, I would give these up for like
5,000 and be like, man, I made it.
And it's like no, it’s worth way more than $5,000.
So I, if I was, if,
if I was a good businessman or a real
estate agent, maybe, but I'm just
like, I know my situation right now.
And I would, I would sell those
things, or I would get the rent.
That's where I'm standing.
- C.J., $5,000. [Laughing]
- That’s just, like, unattainable for me.
So that's what every sneaker to
me that I can't get my hands on,
that's, they’re 5,000 bucks.
- Fine.
Cool.
- So there's a couple of
things about me, right?
Like, I've never been the
avant-garde fashion guy.
I don't think I've ever owned
anything from a major, a high-
fashion, high-price retail brand.
So me owning the Diors feels
like kind of a clout chase. It
kind of feels like I'm stunting.
And if my first
item from Dior is a pair of sneakers,
it's kinda like, what are
we really doing with life,
right?
So that'd be the first thing,
but they're fire, though.
Let's let's, let's, let's
be, let's be honest.
This isn't their fucking fire,
right?
But,
there was a wise philosopher, Jimmy
McMillan, who once stated
that the rent is too damn high!
All right.
We live in a major city.
I live in New York City,
where the average rent—
y’all wildin’ coming here living, first of all—
the average rent is $3,000,
$3,000 in Manhattan, right?
Or even 2,000, just like you
said, we'll go to L.A.—$12,000
I can get.
These things are going for like 1,825.
You're telling me I could get
$12,000 for, for that, one time.
I think it's something that I consider.
- I mean, I want to say, I hear you
considering it, but like, I think,
Christian, I think you made a
great point about sitting on it for a
year, sitting on it for two years and
seeing that value double over time.
Jeff, like, I know that you can get
a nice little 10, 12K lump sum,
but what if it could be 40K?
What if it could be 50K?
- All right.
Well, let's talk about it.
We going to talk about
financial freedom today. [Laughing]
Let's, let's get into it.
Now.
I could take that $12,000, and I can
invest it in a whole lot of ways.
What if I buy three or four other
kicks that are kind of priced
in the same way and sit on those
and then flip those in a year?
I could probably double up what
I have on the Diors.
Plus, you're also considering the fact
that people actually have the money to
buy these sneakers.
Maybe if you, maybe if you fall upon a
celeb or athlete or somebody who has
that much disposable income that they're
going to pay for that, then God bless you.
But other than that, I
could take that money.
I could flip it in the stock market.
I can do, I can do a
whole lot of other things.
It might be even smarter to wait
the next year and flip it for the
40K that you're talking about.
Cuz either way, you're
going to get that money.
- Is there going to be a next year, though?
I hate to harp on that.
- Right?
- But Jeff, OK.
- You want to look
fresh in the apocalypse? [Laughing]
Or do you want some money to barter?
- You always want to look fresh, Jeff. [Laughing]
- I don't want to be too cynical
here, but I want to bring up
what Jeff said earlier, too.
For most of us, this would
be our first Dior piece,
right?
So like, and I, I feel like the philosophy
in this group has always been
wear your sneakers, wear your sneakers.
I don't know how I'm going to pull off
a pair of Dior sneakers with my Ninja
Turtles shirt. Right now, for an on-camera thing,
I'm wearing a Santa Claus Hawaiian shirt.
Like, we know my, my fashion.
So like, I can't be, you can't
go like ‘90s, ‘80s pop
culture outfit and then boom,
$18,000
Diors on the feet.
- Why not? Why not? It's fashion.
I would actually expect you to wear that.
And somebody on the outside would be
like, 'Oh, I know he got money,' because
to pull all that off and then wear the
Diors, I know he's probably an
exec somewhere.
- No, he’s either an exec or some YouTube
vlogger that that's like, Yeah,
- TikTok stars gettin' paid.
- But Jeff, C.J, like, we're sneakerheads.
So what if the Dior's our first
pair? Like, your one step this way,
only if it's right.
It only makes sense, man.
- That's a good way to start, for sure.
- I mean, yeah.
Well, why not,
right?
But I mean, I just, you know,
it's, I'm not saying that I'm,
I'm against wearing those
brands or having them.
It's just, I've never really owned
anything like that before more, so for me—
but do believe I copped those...
your weddings, your graduation
parties, quinceaneras, bar mi—, bat mitzvahs.
I'm wearing them everywhere.
All the major occasions,
you gonna see me fresh in them
Diors.
- See, no, that's what's the right
thing is like, if you have a pair
and you know how to split it up into
a bunch of pieces of content, you're
really getting your investment,
you know? I'm going to sneaker cleaners.
I'm doing YouTube pranks with them.
I'm doing, you know, again, I hate
to, I'm not a vlogger—maybe secretly
I want to be—but, like, if you know how
to split this up in a sneaker content
for B/R Kicks, then maybe these are worth
it instead of getting that rent paid.
- So can we talk quickly about my
guy with the video going around?
He's eating cereal, Cocoa
Puffs, outside of Dior.
We're talking about people
with disposable income.
I know that these shoes are
retailing for $2,000, but
why are we disrespecting the sneaker
game by putting cereal in our shoes?
- Wait, he's eating out of the Diors like that?
- He's putting the cereal in the shoe,
pouring milk on top of it, spoon in
the, in the, in the, where your foot go.
Scooping out.
- See, that's like a whole 'fuck
you' to like all the people—that's a 'fuck
you' to people who don't got $2,000, that have lost
the raffle, who wear their kicks
and who's really about the culture.
Like, that's the type of
stuff that I'm talking about.
These are the people who get, that have
50,000 stacks of a, of a release of
Jordan 1s in pick a color, and people
who really want them can't get it.
You know what I mean?
That's why I'm kinda like, yo, at this
point, should I keep them so that
another hypebeast don't get ‘em?
Now you know, Christian, from a
philosophical perspective,
I'm kinda like maybe I need to protect
the culture and keep them and frame
it like it's the Mona Lisa or
some shit.
- Protect it from bad guys.
Like, don't, we don't want
our precious cargo in the wrong hands.
- Vigilante sneakerheads.
- We're sneakerhead vigilantes! [Laughing]
- It's so wild that we are in
situations where you enter a raffle—
and I know they said don't call it
a raffle—but if you win, you can
pay $2,000 for a pair of sneakers.
Oh, thank you for that privilege
that I am now afforded the opportunity
to spend $2,000 on a pair of
Jordans that we've seen white and
gray, white and stone colorways.
It really is just that like, OK,
again, peek into the future, guys.
See how far that Louis, remember
when the Louis Vuitton, whether
they were bootleg or not,
when Louis Vuitton started
doing the swooshes on a pair
of white-on-white Air Forces.
Like, I'm scared of what the Dior print is
going to start looking like on all these
other sneakers that then devalue the
Diors, you know.
- That's true.
I didn't think about that.
- I still want it for the drip.
- I know.
No, you're in the moment, Meech.
- I got to get a fit off.
- Also, low key,
talk about the most, like, nerve-
wracking walk back home.
Like, you got the Diors in hand.
- No, you got to take the Uber.
You got to call the Uber as
soon as you get out the store.
- Yeah.
- Point to point, door to door.
I'm not—hell no.
Door to door in my Diors.
I sound like Pop Smoke right now. [Laughing]
- This is why I'm excited for the NBA to come
back. Because I heard P.J. Tucker, he brought
60 pairs, and I would put money down that
one of those 60 pairs has to be the Dior
1s. And if in the Western Conference Finals—
I'm not predicting this—
but, like, P.J. pulls them out—
ooh!
- To ball in!
- Yeah.
- He's balled in 1s before.
- He has. He definitely has.
- I believe it.
- Thinking about this before. When
I first saw them, like, when I first saw
the link that had dropped, like at first,
I was like, here we go again.
But then I was thinking like, yo, I really need to,
like, look for like the size
14, 15s that they have there.
Just so I can cop it.
- And then resell to a ballplayer?
- Fantastic!
- That's the right thinking, Christian.
You're like, Oh, should I get my size?
No, get it for the players who
have the money to buy them.
- Right, right.
- You're going to do the type of delivery
where like, 'Hey, here's my address,
come by.'
And it's going to be a whole, like,
exchange.
- You know, you got to pull
up, you got to pull up like outside
of MSG, like, 'Yo, I know you didn't
get those Diors. Come talk to me.
What's your size? I got your size.'
- Name for me,
name five players for me that
you guys think would rock the
Dior Jordan 1s on court.
- P.J., let's get it.
- Obviously. P.J. is No. 1.
- P.J., of course.
- JR Smith.
- Of course. JR
of course.
- Devin Booker maybe.
No, not Devin.
He's wearing Kobes. Um...
- Montrezl will wear them.
- Oh, yeah.
- These are current, right? Current?
- Yeah, guys that are on teams right now.
- I think he's agnostic.
He'll wear whatever he wants.
- Montrezl?
- Yeah, right?
Or is he Reebok?
- Well, he, ah, he is Reebok.
That is true.
But I thought I've seen him wear
Kobes this year.
So, maybe.
- Yeah. I would say, I mean,
I would have said, uh, Shai,
but he just signed with Converse.
- He could still do it. He could still do it.
- That's still family, right?
- Yeah, it's still family.
Like, you know, Kobe was wearing Jordans.
You know what I mean?
Like you could, you could do it, but I
don't think, I think out the gate, they
would want them to wear, you know
what I'm saying?
- Converse is like, 'Let it cool off a little bit.'
- 'Let it heat up a little, Shai, let it heat up.'
- Here's another thing.
Cuz I would've said Kuz,
but he just got signed.
So now I'm like, are all these
guys making wild sneaker choices?
Like, I would have even said Oubre, but, like,
these guys have made wild, like, distinct,
uh, choices in their footwear.
They're all signed now.
Like, that's how they're making waves.
- I feel like my, my dark horse is Luka.
I feel like if he came out and
he rocked the, he rocked the Diors,
the world would implode.
- Well, so yeah,
Jordan Brand athletes.
Luka, Zion.
- Tatum.
- Would he rock them on court?
- Maybe just shootaround type deal.
- If they're down in the series, he would, I
feel like. 'Someone's got to talk about me.'
He's got that Mamba mentality.
If he's not winning, he's got
to win in some other category.
- Right.
- So, the story behind the Diors was
the Dior family, their company,
they made 13,000 pairs, right?
Five thousand were for top Dior clients.
The rest of the 8,000 that was left
over was for the rest of the world.
What if they made more than that
13K?
You know, what if they did
130,000?
What does that look like for Dior?
What does that look for me?
Would I have a pair?
- I don't know.
I don't know what
the math is. Somebody could do the math
on the side, like Jeff said, but if five
million people trying to cop them, and
you have five million pairs, what's that?
- Ten billion?
- Ten billion with a B.
Yeah.
- Would anybody try to cop them?
- Yes, of course.
We didn't know ahead of time
that it was that exclusive.
We knew it was exclusive, but
only 8,000 pairs available?
- If I come in, if I come in the house,
no matter how, if I told my wife,
'Oh yeah, I won this raffle in 2K,'
and then I still drive a Nissan Cube?
That's not a good conversation.
You know when it really doesn't work? When
five pairs show up on one day. [Laughing]
And you're just like,
yeah, 'Nike did their, their clearance.'
And it's just like, 'No.' It's
still your money that you
don't—'You only have two feet.'
- Right.
It is true.
- But I do, like, all
those shoes I go, 'But yeah, I
got hooked up through Bleacher Report.
They sent us a pair to try.'
- 'They just sent them today.'
- 'All these shoes are a hundred bucks.
I got them media days.
Yeah,
they just sent them to me.
I'm a huge Laker fan.'
- C.J.,
I want you to also think about
too, like, yeah, you'll be rocking
the Diors in a Cube, but like,
what about that, that picture
when you step out the car
- Yeah.
- and your foot hits the ground, bro?
You know, like I can be there
to capture that for you.
- I would love that. Like a slow-mo, like me
coming out of my Nissan Cube, and then it
would only be like, it would touch the
ground, but I wouldn't press my foot down.
- Cuz you couldn't crease it.
You could't crease it.
And then I would be like, 'Cut!'
And then I would put them right
back in the box, take a
picture, throw them on StockX.